yo boo like kid podcast episode number
not sure to be honest somewhere in the
in the about to hit 40.
close to 40. you know what i'm saying uh
we've got special guest haiti baby in
the building thanks for having me dog
west coast
what's going on new uh album trap art
yes sir
dropping january 29th january 29th
that's that [ __ ] that's
that's next friday man so uh we got to
talk i want to know man
so you came up to me in a dj head show
yeah about a year and a half ago
let's come on come on did the freestyle
come on
and it went [ __ ] crazy yeah it was it
was two ways they could have went like
you already know
yeah no after it was done me and head
talked to we're like man this shit's
either about to go viral
as [ __ ] or it's or it's gonna no one's
gonna [ __ ] with it
yeah and it went crazy yeah um
first of all talk about your approach
into because you're a smart guy yeah so
did you know what you were doing you're
a smart guy um
i knew what i was doing of course i
didn't think it was gonna land me a
re-read feature
or meek mill follow chrissy teigen
that's how you pronounce her name
chrissy teigen yeah okay i don't wanna
mess it up um
i didn't think it was gonna do all that
i thought i was gonna get a viral buzz
you know how quick you know how you go
viral and the buzz goes away like the
yeah that stamp always can be like i can
stop making music next year and
my name will still pop up somehow and
that just keeps people like oh i never
heard this kid let me check the spotify
extremes go up like
the the pros and cons to the free to the
freestyle when i wrote out my own list
about it it was so many pros
like it was so much positivity came
after like i went gold
because of that i gained 122 followers
because of it
so it's just it was a weird experience i
came to you with 50k followers
yeah so bro [ __ ] went up after that that
was dope
it was i mean i got i got badge for what
i got but i never been the type to run
away from pressure right
that's probably because i play sports
most likely but [ __ ]
is what it is and um i'm looking forward
to i'm looking forward to my future
because i'm just evolving now as a man
yeah it's crazy because you know i
remember
just like when diesel samara talked
about it on show
time and then like you said rihanna
chrissy teigen was like
she she was like yeah she was the
biggest was she the first
i don't know but she was like going
going hard for that freestyle she's like
i can't stop watching it
yeah a lot of artists have some good
comments sway lee
lil yachty meek mill posted it mcmahon
posted it but a lot of the newer
generational artists had a lot of good
comments
of course oh heads they feedback always
going to be stern
there's yeah there's either two no wrong
with that though yeah if there's some
people who say
you you go on facebook i still get
tagged to this day it'll be like the
worst freestyle ever
right and then some people thought it
was [ __ ] crazy the best freestyle
ever
right right right right hey take it you
hate it eleven i don't really
what what were the cons of the freestyle
um
the my crowd around me my back home
people you know
seeing people fold seeing people like
you stand by my side when it when you
see oh riri and mcmilla when she was
standing by my side right before that
he was quick to leave so it was it was a
good way to catch all the catch all the
snakes in the in the land you know what
i'm saying
but other than that like the pros
outfield it like it just it was just so
much good stuff happened happened after
that like
i i was able to i was able to actually
like create a whole new sound
off of that like off of that like but i
you i got a shout out to empire and
ghazi like
i'm able to be free with my artistic
side dress how i want to dress do what i
want to do
right even if somebody says oh that's
not right you make your own suggestions
but as an artist i'm free
i'm not controlled so i can do what i
want you know what i'm saying so shout
out to them for
even allowing me to go to go up there
and um you release the [ __ ] because i
know [ __ ] like oh we ain't
gonna release it
but hey it made my career you know some
part of my legacy no no yeah
i think that there was a very we were
all
at the end of the freestyle very uh
we we didn't know what the [ __ ] we were
very confused your face is totally
that's all i need but you ain't
you and i had some good friends now yeah
yeah yeah you talk to me all the time
yeah
i think it it it was a positive though
man i think people i think at the end of
the day like you said i kind of laid the
groundwork for you kind of
you from there you could do anything you
lit like if when people think about it
from there like you can drop
songs like i did blue dragon where go
under 3000 completely off
go off the off the off the reservoir off
the red you know because i'm not your
regular rapper so right
i created my own box and now i'm living
in it